and it gives me great pleasure to
welcome you all to the Simon's Institute
as well as other speaks workshop for
those who may not know
um the Simon's Institute is the leading
venue for uh collaborative research in
TCS theoretical computer science and it
was established in 2012 with a very
generous Grant from the summons
Foundation which continues to support us
significantly and The Institute brings
together the world's leading researchers
in the theory of computing and related
fields as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars and we are
now in the second decade of programs at
The Institute they start at 2013 so this
is the you know 11th year of programs
and we're really proud of the
achievements of the wide-ranging
programs which have
pushed the frontiers of TCS in so many
directions making progress on
long-standing challenges of the field as
well as opening up new directions of
inquiry and common points with other
fields so each semester we have two
programs that attract several long-term
visitors Junior and senior to Berkeley
and these programs also include multiple
workshops that convene more short-term
visitors on a weekly basis and so this
is one of the the first workshops for
the logic and algorithms program so I
would like to you to welcome to this
Workshop which is titled fine-grained
complexity logic and query evaluation
and uh I would like to thank the
organizers for their hard work in
putting together a program for this
workshop and they are hung no
I think they're all here or yeah
hunger's here
um cut Crews
and Virginia Williams so thank you let's
give them a round of applause
and uh a few logistics for the coming
week before I hand it over to the
scientific organizers so food is
provided before the first talk and at
the breaks and for lunch you're on your
own but there are many options close by
and you have a long long lunch break so
it should be no problem
and we please ask that you leave any
food and drinks including coffee outside
the auditorium it really helps us keep
the place uh you know clean as it is as
you can see and if you want to store
things when you go for lunch or outside
there are lockers in the backs other
side of the building where you can store
your things and as always all the talks
everything is live streamed uh and you
can also you know the videos will be
available on the website and we have uh
videographer Omid who help us with help
with any speakers any AV issues and just
another thing about publicity if any of
you are active on Twitter and you're
sort of live Tweeting or I guess a live
exiting I should say
um
um the workshop please uh tag at Simon's
Institute and then we will be you know
sure to repost it will be good
for the workshop and people know what's
going on and uh and last but not least
uh like to give a special round of
thanks for events coordinate events
coordinators Ashley Hassan and Freda Orr
for all the hard work managing all the
logistics so that the workshops run
smoothly as they always do and they will
also be on hand all week to answer any
questions you might have so with that
I'll hand things over to the organizers
in particular hung who will say a few
words about the workshops thank you and
have a great week
all right thank you venkat so welcome to
the second Workshop of the logic and
algorithms program so from the first
workshop and the past month or so until
now I hope you have um you know those of
you who have followed the talks and also
discussions you have realized that um
complexity community and the database
Community have been solving really the
same set of problems and the only
missing link is really a query language
to express their problems and the query
language is logic so this Workshop is
fine print complexity logic and inquiry
evaluation and you see that logic is the
the link that is connecting to the two
communities and because we're solving
the same set of problems it would be
really nice for us to talk to each other
and the whole of this Workshop is to
create themes under which the two
communities can
further
um you know Express the problems and the
techniques that we use to solve those
problems and the workshop is uh is
divided into five themes five days so
first day will be non-recursive query
evaluation uh the second day will be an
MPC
um I might be messing up the order of
those days a little bit on Wednesday
that will be oh the second day is on
relational algorithm uh Wednesday it
will be on massively parallel
computation model on Thursday that will
be on recursive query evaluation and
then lastly it will be in incremental
view maintenance also known as Dynamic
algorithms so you will see that there's
really the same collection of problems
that we are solving in in different
communities and because of that we would
ruin it like you know people to talk to
each other uh uh uh you know like across
the aisle if you will and so we are
experimenting with um with a format in
which in every day there will be at one
top from each of the communities and
then in the afternoon we create
opportunities for people to discuss the
ideas and the problems
um that way and so I'm going to give the
mic to Atri who is running the you know
the first day in Virginia the First
theme and then he will explain a little
more on this experimentation and we you
know very much welcome more ideas on how
to get people talk to each other more
actually
all right thanks Hank uh hello everyone
um
sorry I'm just gonna add lip for a
little bit so uh things might not come
in the most polish way that it should
um so uh as hung mentioned the idea uh
this theme for today is non-recursive
database queries how many of you
actually understand what that means I'm
just curious
oh
all right uh
how many of you would consider more of
yourself most as a database Theory
I think intersection is almost
completely different okay good uh so as
hung mentioned the idea uh for today and
indeed the entire Workshop is uh folks
who would primarily consider themselves
to be database researchers talk to
people who would consider them social
family algorithms researchers again it
demarcations are not strict of course
um so
um the plan for today is we're gonna
have two talks uh we're gonna have uh no
for carmeli give a two-part talk first
uh on
uh non-recursive like
um
like going beyond what you all might if
you were in the boot camp have seen
about uh you know solving non-recursive
code database queries
um and then we'll have Andrea Lincoln uh
talk about for 45 minutes on
fine-grained complexity uh the
experimentation that talked about in the
afternoon uh is really an experiment at
the sense that we made it up made it up
half an hour ago but we would really
like your health but the main goal of
that the afternoon sessions after lunch
is so that we can really have cross
collaborations and people talking to
each other so the way we're going to
start off with two is uh
thanks you know for agreeing to that as
well she's gonna start off us with a
very concrete open problem that's open
and work on
um we will figure out some groups have
you all break up into groups and then
you can kind of go outside upstairs kind
of talk about it
um then after the break at 3 30 you will
kind of get back together and see how it
goes so we really ask for your patience
and health as I said uh we are excited
about this but we haven't done anything
like this ever at least I haven't uh so
we will see how things go uh so we
definitely love your feedback as we go
back are there any questions on I think
it's important people have to get back
here too yes so two things if please be
back here at two uh we definitely need
your help to kind of if you're not here
then it's not gonna work and do please
also come back at 3 30 even though I
think the schedule says quote unquote
option please do come back and at least
give us feedback on how your group's
discussion went so that uh if need be we
can okay
is really the model that the American
Institute of mathematics adopt I mean
exact English format very few talks and
groups but they usually it was a list of
problems so that people can ponder and
consider them
yes so uh uh both Andrea and nofa will
talk about open questions in the talks
within the morning today they'll have it
but also at two when we start that
session we're going to start off with a
concrete uh questions for folks too I
was asking if you can pause for tomorrow
the day after oh uh
okay uh thank you for the suggestion we
will uh talk about it and see if we can
get that done um
I don't see Paris space
we will try I think that's a good idea
um I I think one of the things we wanted
to do at least for today was especially
for people who are not familiar this is
today is the day to kind of you know get
to know kind of the various areas uh but
I think going forward that might be more
feasy
yeah I understand
I understand yeah yeah
every evening there was a get-together
and every group saying what they've done
are you planning something yeah so the
330 that's what I said the schedule says
optional so I'm requesting everyone not
to take it as optional and come back and
discuss what happened from two to three
at 3 30 yes thank you
cool
any other questions
sorry I'm teaching two undergrad courses
this semester so I'm very much like are
there any questions they're all good
okay
uh 3 30 PM when you report back with
what your group did
all right so uh I guess without further
Ado Let's uh start off with our first
talk uh from you know for carmeli uh you
know for is affiliated with the India
and at Monterey uh done bunch of great
work uh on
um uh kind of solving database queries
uh
her talk is going to be answering
questions so typically at least my
background algorithms you kind of think
of like it's an offline problem someone
gives you a database query or a graph
problem you solve it and then a certain
amount of time but in databases you have
additional requirements like you want
like answers happening in an online
fashion and so on and so forth
um but okay thank you
anyone hear me
um
right so I'm really happy to be here I
think this is uh amazing because as a
person who tries to work on database
problems but in terms of fine grain
complexity of the database problems I
really feel like from the discussions
that I had with fine-grained complexity
people they really have like nice
insights about how these things can be
solved so I think this is a huge
opportunity what's happening now I'm
very happy to be here
so the point of the talk is
um to understand uh query valuation and
how we can how or when we can do this
with what we would call Ideal uh time
guarantees and I'll try to to focus so
the idea would be that if you want to
work on these things later you'll have
like the basis to do that so I'll try to
not just tell you what we know but
explain a bit how these things work on
examples and point out the open problems
it's a long talk
um scheduled to be 40 minutes five
minutes break and then 40 minutes but I
guess we will have 10 minutes less than
that but still uh feel free to stop me
so that it's not just me standing here
for very long and like let's make it a
discussion
um
Solutions remarks whatever you want
okay no good
uh yeah so this is the plan of the talk
uh we're going to start by talking about
the task of enumerating all answers to a
database here I will start with just
considering the most basic form of
queries which is joints and then we'll
slowly increase the expressivity until
we reached unions of conjective queries
and then if I have time I also talk
about other tasks that are not just
outputting all of the answers to the
query
so let's start with join queries
um let's make sure we all understand
what a join query is so this is an
example for a database that describes a
lab and the problems in the lab so we
have one relation which is a table that
describes the problems in certain rooms
we have a table that describes who are
the people in each office and a table
that describes what are the contexts
contact information for
uh and let's say we want to send a bunch
of emails to all of the people who have
problems in their offices so what we
need to do here is to join the three
relations uh one way we could write this
query is what you see here and if you
want to understand what this query means
in set notation just because it's the
first slide this is what it means
okay so what happens is that clear for
everyone
what happens if we want to answer
queries of this form
first of all we should be aware that
there could be many answers when I say
many I mean more than linear so if we're
joining two relations and it so happens
that all of the topos agree on the join
variables then we get the size of the
output is the size of the first relation
times the size of the second equation
so not linear if we have more relations
it can be even more than
the second thing we should be aware of
is that if we're not careful we can have
a lot of intermediate answers so in this
case if we're trying to join these three
relations at the end of the day we only
have one answer but if we're first
joining R and S and then joining the
result we see then we get that the
number of intermediate answers in
disproportionate both to the size of the
input and to the size of the output
meaning the computation would
necessarily take a long time because it
goes through all of these intermediates
this is something we want to avoid
okay
um no
um
one thing we can notice here is that we
have what we call dangling tapos these
are tuples that are part of the input
but for this specific query they don't
affect the output
if we had a way of magically identifying
them and removing them it would make in
this case the list of intermediate
answers to be smaller and it save us
time
so let's go back to the example we saw
one thing we can do is we go over the
relations uh one pair at a time and
filter them so we go over the office
relation uh we remove information about
offices that don't have problems we go
over the contact relation remove
information about
um the people who are not relevant for
problems in offices we go back to the
office remove the information about
people whose contacts we don't have
and continue like this remove
information about rooms that are not an
office
so for this query this works well right
we managed to remove on the ending
couples we just need to join what's left
we can do that efficiently
what happens with other queries
this is another example for a query this
one describes
um university we have a list of which
students are registered to which exams
we have a table that describes which
exams are given by which professors and
the table that describes conflicts of
interest between students
um we want to know whether we have a
problematic case where students and a
professor that have a conflict of
interest are involved in the same exam
now over this
um over this input the answers would be
nothing right there are no answers for
example n Only Takes algorithms
algorithm is given by PL and NPR don't
have
um a conflict of interest and so on this
is supposed to be Anna the same
um
but if we try to remove the dangling
tapos by comparing phase Paradise
relations we see that we don't succeed
right we cannot filter one of the
relations according to another relation
um and the way you can see this visually
is you can draw this graph that
corresponds to the query
and you can draw this graph that
corresponds to the database and
basically what this join query tells you
is it asks you to find the query pattern
in the database graph so it asks you to
find all homomorphisms from this graph
to that graph
um and the way the algorithm worked
before is it tells you okay if you see
some entity that's only connected to
Yellow but not connected to Blue you
know it won't be useful so you can
remove that but here you don't have this
everything is connected to all colors
but the database gives you a six cycle
while the query gives you a three cycle
so it's hard to identify that you don't
have this query
is that clear for everyone
okay so this was supposed to be some
intuition uh on specific examples but
let's see what happens when we want to
make that more General
so first of all we'll be talking in data
complexity uh and this means that we
abstract away the size of the query so
when I say linear time we mean linear in
the size of the database
um
the we should keep in mind that the
number of answers can be polynomial in
the size of the input database
uh in a way what are the minimal
requirements we can expect to achieve so
we need at least linear time in order to
read the input and then to know whether
there are any answers or not and then we
need at least constant temperature in
order to print all of the output
we'll be using the ram model for
computation and later in the talk will
also allow logarithmic factors on top of
what I said now but I'll tell you when
this happens
one thing we could do is uh what we call
worst case optimal algorithms and this
means that the time that the algorithm
takes is linear in the size of the input
plus the worst case output
so for example if we want to find
triangles in a graph with M edges uh the
the
worst case or the the highest number of
triangles such a graph can have is m to
the 1.5 so this algorithm is allowed to
take m to the 1.5 time even if there are
no triangles in the input graph
um this is what we know is the Aging
bound and there are known
um worst case optimal algorithms that we
can apply for our joint queries what if
we want to do better than that right so
we don't want linear time in the worst
case output but we want linear time in
the specific output we have
so this would be in a way instance
optimal total time
uh and it's better over most inputs
and then something that would be even
nicer than that is if we can have this
sort of regular delay between answers so
we would have this guarantee that we
will get the first answer only after
linear time in the input and then we'll
get a constant stream of answers with
constantly
so anyway this is this is the best we
can hope for if we want to print all of
the answers to it
okay the focus on our talk will be this
enumeration
all of our algorithms would be this
which means that they also give us
instance optimal linear time most of the
hardest results I will just talk in
terms of enumeration but most of the
harness results I tell you also apply
for just instance of just for the total
time so this is also really relevant for
everything I say in the stock even if I
want to explicitly mention that
okay
the long-term goal would be we're given
a query a user wants to compute this
query what is the most efficient
algorithm we can have for that specific
query
an intermediate question would be we're
given a query let's consider some time
complexity can we answer this query with
this time guarantees
and then we have two ways of answering
this question either yes and then we do
an algorithm or no and then we want to
prove that we cannot do that and in the
remodel we don't have a way of just
proving proving things unconditionally
so we're going to use conditional lower
bounds and this is uh in a way how we're
really big users of fine grain
complexity work because we're going into
papers and seeing like what kind of
hypothesis we can use to prove that our
things work that would make sense and
stuff like that
okay so
um what makes the distinction between
the yes or no in the case of enumerating
the answers to join queries but maybe
not surprisingly after the visualization
we saw before the key is a cyclicity so
this corresponds to the notion of alpha
cyclicity in hypergraphs but let me give
you one of the definitions a query is a
cyclic if it has a jointery
so joint three is a graph that describes
the query where there is a node for
every atom of the query
um maybe less than here I don't know
your simulator
there's a node for every atom of the
query this graph is a tree and if we
consider every variable separately look
only at the nodes that contain this
variable then these nodes are connected
so the square is a cyclic but not all
queries are cyclic this query for
example is cyclic because if we want to
make it a tree we need two out of the
three possible edges no matter which
Edge we choose to leave out we will have
some variable that's not connected
foreign
tells us if the query is a cyclic then
we have an algorithm with linear key
processing and constant delay if the
query is cyclic then search an algorithm
doesn't exist
assuming two things that I will explain
in more details later so one thing is
that it only applies to queries without
self joins and the other thing is of
course we have conditional lower bounds
so we need some uh hypotheses for that
to work but let's start by explaining
the positive side
so this is very example to very similar
to the example you saw before let's say
we want to join these relations first
thing we do we take a joint tree and we
set some Roots arbitrarily I don't care
which route you take
then there is a process that removes
dangling tuples so we go over the tree
twice yes
one sentence about how you find the
joint Junior
well in data complexity It's Magic
but it shouldn't be problematic so for
example you can start by taking a leaf
which is a node that all of the
variables that are shared with other
variables are shared with only one
really
connected to that
okay
um
so we removed dangling Toppers
um we go over the the
three in two parts first we start from
uh two passes yeah first we start from
the leaves we go to the root and we
filter every parent according to the
child and then we also go uh
so for example here we can start like
this
then we filter R3 according to R4 so we
see we have no W3 here so this would
never be used
and we continue like this we filter out
one according to R3 since we already
removed this double we know that Z3 will
never be used so we can remove also that
we continue like this
and then we go down and filter the
children according to the parents when
this process ends we are guaranteed that
we have no dangling topples left
and all we need to do is join which we
can do efficiently for example by just
having uh nested for Loops so we start
by going all of the tuples we have left
in the roots and then we go over all of
the taposing a child that match what we
have left what we took in The Roots we
can do that efficiently with the
appropriate data structures and continue
any questions about the algorithm
yeah could you give me like a one
sentence intuition about why two passes
is enough
um so the key here is that this is a
joint tree
um
and then this is the key this I know
like you won't have any surprises right
you won't
start by knowing that you need to filter
something and then need to filter
something and then something changed and
then you need to fill the recording to
that again because it's all connected
a simple observation that is based on uh
considering a sub query that is defined
by one as a note of the tree
when you do the if to root semi joint
reduction then you're guarantee that
each relation will be reduced with
respect to just the subquery
no no questions are good I don't want to
just talk to myself any more questions
okay
uh that was the the positive side now
for the negative side
um
so uh let me mention the uh one way of
proving that that was the original uh
way that was known for a while now
um so this is the query
um that we saw before that we said it's
a bit harder and maybe not surprisingly
um so first of all let's rename things
again to make it easier to work with
maybe not surprisingly we can prove that
this query is hard if we assume the
triangle finding in a graph is hard
um so the assumption is that we cannot
detect triangles in a graph in linear
time
and let's say we have a graph we want to
know whether it contains triangles and
then we encode the religions in the
graphs in the three the edges of the
graphs and the three relations
um and then by definition this query
just finds the triangles
so if we find the first answer in linear
time we determine that there is a
triangle in linear time which is
something we assume
uh right so this was for uh that
particular query we want to say
something similar for any cyclical query
and we can do this with a generalization
of this hypothesis
um
so the the generalization is about
finding hyperclicks so here we mean k
vertices such that each K minus one of
them forms an edge so when k equals
three it's a triangle but we can also
assume that for larger K and the
assumption is that deciding whether such
a thing exists in a hyper graph cannot
be done in linear
and basically
um what we know is that if a hypograph
is cyclic then it contains necessarily
contains such a thing as an induced
subgraph so either exactly such a thing
or a triangle and then we can use a
cycle and then we can use a triangle so
we can apply a similar reduction in any
cyclic query basically
um
okay
I'll put in this question of comment in
these two brothers so when you're
talking about cycling all right cycling
if all your relations have only two
attributes this is just saying you look
at the graph
of corresponded to query and it's either
a forest or not
it's more complicated right right
foreign
oh that's a great point and I'm going to
I'm going to discuss this in more
details
more questions
no remarks yeah for the less hyper click
on Lower bound
Aries
yeah I'm going to talk about that
so what did you use where did you use in
this proof the fact that there are no
not self joints
I'm going to talk about that
are not related to self joins yes
so the Triangular assumption is enough
when you have binary relations but if
you have larger than binary relations so
for example if your query looks exactly
like this then no you cannot just use
the triangle or I don't see how you can
do that
so why did you only assume that it that
hyperclick can be done in linear time we
believe it's much harder well that's
what I need so I just assume the minimum
I need interesting in our original paper
yeah
okay
so if we have a stronger assumption
maybe we can say something about not
just that you can't do it with linear
pre-processing but you can't even do it
for larger pre-processing
um but I just don't I mean I just don't
talk about it at all for the sake of
Simplicity but actually in our research
we didn't mention it in any paper for
the sake of Simplicity maybe we should
that's a good that's a good point yeah
if you increase the pain right
um
yes because we're talking about edges
okay
so before I move on to the next part of
the talk which is self-joins I know
you're all waiting for that
um I just want to mention a few things
about the raw model because it's
something that I found really confusing
in the beginning and people are still
like constantly asking me but why does
it make sense so I want to tell you why
it makes sense from my point of view
so what does it mean
first of all we need to
put the input in our memory right
and then we need
the registers to be able to contain
addresses of all of the memory we have
so it makes sense to consider that the
length of the registers is logarithmic
okay so we assume that
if we consider that the length of the
registers is logarithmic
it means that we have a bound on the The
Domain values right we need to assume
something on the the length of the
registers it gives us a bound on the
values we can put inside
this means that if for example we want
to sort a relation we don't have to be a
com to do it to do a comparison based
sort
we can do something like Radix sort that
would give us sorting in linear time not
and again linear
okay
we assume that we can do basic
operations in constant time
and then there are different variants
that people use in different papers
about how much memory is available but
for example if we assume that we have a
polynomial amount of memory available
then it means that if we have lookup
tables like the sort of hash tables they
can be perfect hash tables we can just
put a value in the address that matches
to it and then check to see if the value
is there so we can do this in really
constant time logarithmic uh not
constant in expectations really constant
time okay
uh then there are different variants on
the
um what memory you're allowed to touch
uh and not just so we're allowed to to
touch everything or just a linear uh
amount of cells and there are variants
about what you can touch during
enumeration so some people say that for
real real constant delay enumeration is
when you only have a few pointers during
the enumeration that you're allowed to
move and then for other papers you need
to really save all of the answers you've
seen and use a lot of memory
um so just be aware that these are
things that happen in papers if you're
writing a paper like for database people
make sure you're clear on what variant
you're using please
[Laughter]
and
and then so why so I explain now why I
think it makes sense from the
theoretical point of view
and then from the Practical point of
view this is a bit weird but it only
saves you logarithmic factors from what
you would expect that you can really do
and in practice blogs are not that
important so it still makes sense so all
models are wrong but some models are
still useful so this is useful I think
and this is why I think it makes sense
are you going to access
well you can modify everything you can
access
yes
yes is there any other question was
about this two-dimensional lookup tables
if you see it like that there's this
observation that's in the Run model you
can augment it by supposing that you
have bi-dimensional varieties and that
makes it potentially more expressive I
don't know
yeah yeah let's talk about it later
so something that Louis did
yes
ah no you're just stretching
[Laughter]
connectivity like the nodes are having
the same valuable so has this one
exploded
like uh you're talking about a psychic
Service is like a tree yeah you have
boundary trees
yes so basically if the query is a
cyclic then it has bounded tree with the
treated three with this one but then if
the truth is larger you can do similar
things but you just need to pay more
like that depends on the tree
um so that is correct if the relations
have Rarity too but if for higher
everyday relations is no longer a
treatment it's uh
[Music]
I have to deal with a lot with customers
complaining why in their queries are
slow okay
is about 30 or so okay and you know
query running in one minute versus a
query running in 30 minutes makes a big
difference yeah
okay
thank you in the comments I just want to
say that if you write paper savings or
not Factor please do
foreign
good point
um do you think this says anything about
the Ramona
okay
cool
uh okay in this talk I won't mention all
of the restrictions on memory we assume
that we can do everything we want with
the memory we can ask okay
good and now the moment you've all been
waiting for selfie joins
what are self joins first okay let's
make sure
so we have this little star here
this is a query with self-join so self
joins is when we have
we use the same regulation in different
atoms so here we have two search joints
right this is a query that asks for two
students that sat in the same room
during an exam and got exactly the same
grade
um
what happens to the complexity of this
query so the algorithms don't work
because it's cyclic the hardness results
don't hold because of how self-jones let
me show you why the hardness results
don't hold when there are set of joints
remember this is how we prove that the
triangle query is hard
now what happens if we have that that's
the triangle query what happens if we
introduce another atom and we make a
query of a structure that's similar to
what we saw before but now here we we
don't have software
well the way we would prove it's hard is
we would have a construction where we
we're still reducing from shining loads
but we have edges on three of the sets
and um
we have autism three of the edges on
three of the atoms but in the fourth one
we put equality
so the reduction uh the construction
would look like this this
is so the identity of the notes
the pairs a lot of the notes
so over this construction uh the query
still returns exactly the triangles
uh but if we have a self-join so the
last atom uses exactly the same relation
before we cannot do this construction
anymore we can't assign different
relations to different atoms
okay
good
so
what does it mean about that specific
query
and in general does it mean that it's
just that these specific hardness
results don't hold like the the proofs
don't hold but we would get the same
results with other proofs well we
recently found out
um
thanks to a tutorial by by Kristoff and
his co-authors that queries which have
joins can be easier than queries without
self joins uh and here is uh an example
for when this happens
um
so that's the the query we saw before it
is easy
um let's prove it on a query when where
everything is one big self joins for for
Simplicity this is a query let's take an
example for an input database this is
our database
what are the answers to this query over
that database
so first of all we have the obvious
sensors where so you just
take everything like this right so U
maps to save maps to D and so on
then we have the answers the answer
where you and V are flipped so U takes D
and V tapes takes C then we have the
answers where u and v take the same
value
that's also a homomorphism so you can
see the list of query answers over there
uh and these answers we're we're Uh u
and v take the same value those are the
key here because these are answers that
basically correspond to two paths that
are things that are easy to identify
yeah so just to kind of make sure
um so when you're doing this some joints
uh I'm sorry this is a remote question
uh at least when I'm thinking in terms
of graphs
uh the way I like to visualize these is
if there are four variables you think of
this as a four-partite graph so you have
one domain for x u b and Y and then what
you're having over here are restriction
on what are the edges
and what you're saying is in the general
joint case there's no restriction on say
you take two partitions whether they
have to be the same or not but in some
joints you do and that kind of
basically destroys the hardness thing
because you wanted like this kind and
this kind sorry yeah
I agree yeah
okay
thank you
okay I'll continue then I guess
um
should I help you or like I don't mind
that you're talking but I'm wondering if
I should be part of this too
okay
so these answers we can see because we
have this endomorphism in this query
so in this case if you have a son John
like this then you're saying that the
domain
yes
it's even more than that but in person
so in a query you can return something
where you and B are the same
yes
yes exactly yes
I know I'm really going to show you how
it's easy by showing an algorithm okay
so
um this has answers so the answers that
are not revealed and the answers that
are trivial because they really
correspond to two pass where you and V
get the same value now these answers
that are trivial you can see them
because there is an endomorphism in this
query
so an endomorphism is a homomorphism
from a set to itself here what it means
is a mapping from the variables of the
query to the variables of the query such
that every atom maps to an atom
the image of this endomorphism is the
two path you can look at it as a query
it's a cyclic we can find its answers
efficiently
these are the answers to the two path
query over our database
and these answers give you answers to
the original query these answers are
easy to find you can start enumerating
these first and you get a lot of time
and this time you can use to find also
the answers that are less trivial uh now
how are the answers of the image giving
you the answers to the original query
well you just follow the endomorphism in
the opposite direction
uh
right and then you can so once you find
this to pay two path and these two paths
you just notice that they say they have
the same endpoints and then you find out
that you have something
so the intuition is two paths will have
the output size is pretty large exactly
thank you
give this a second time
okay
yeah
so
the key for why self drawings become
easy is because our goal is listing all
outputs
queries that might not hold
yeah I assume okay
okay
so
for seven joins
this is an open problem in general we
don't know exactly what happens please
help
let me tell you a bit of what we do know
okay
uh we were supposed to go on a break but
I think maybe I'll continue talking
about self joins and we'll do the break
a bit later
so this is the query we just saw I saw I
showed you an algorithm the algorithm is
based on the image you see here that's a
cyclic that you can use the answers to
this image to buy time for computer
here's another query
um it's like the previous one but now I
flip the direction of this Edge
now
let's play a game I asked you do you
guess that it's easy or hard and you
have to say something you want to be
correct because I won't give you enough
time I mean for this maybe but I'll play
this game several times okay so do you
guess that it's easy or hard
okay this query is hard
um you can notice that it doesn't have
endomorphisms other than the identity
now
so we don't have these images we can use
and we can do a similar reduction to
what we did before and let me show you
how we make this reduction work
uh right that's our query this is how we
want to encode the triangle detection
here's a graph we want to know whether
it contains triangles so we pretend for
a moment that we don't have soft joints
and we're allowed to put different
relations in different atoms yes sorry
in this quiz are all the relations same
every time yes yes all of the relations
are the same thank you I didn't say that
so from now on until I say differently
everything is one big self doing
again if I'm thinking in terms of graph
Theory the underlying graph is not
directed because the directions yes
now the directions matter the conclusion
yeah I think I'm having a whole kind of
difficulty what does the picture mean
there
oh I just don't understand so this is
the query
what does it mean
um this is the pattern that you want to
look for in a directed graph that's your
database that's when we have to be the
same and workloads can they can they can
all be different they can all be the
same whatever works
yes
if you have what you're allowed to make
them the same if if that works right so
for example here
uh when
you go back this was your query
then you were allowed to make u and v
map to the same thing if that works for
you
so you don't have to
you you also need to return the answers
where they map to different things
can X and U be the same only if there's
a database entry that's like AAA exactly
okay no
selfie yeah
and you allow yourself yeah
that's what your database says
so again to rephrase you're just finding
all the homomorphisms from this small
pattern yes
yes
right so here let's go back
um here I'm asking I'm giving you a
pattern I want to find all homomorphisms
from this pattern to an input
graph directed graph is this possible
with linear reprocessing and constant
device
and you flip that
so yes for now it's this is the easy
case and now I flip the edge and now I'm
claiming that this is hard so then why
can't you make the top and the right
vertex the same and then I'll become
triangle
you can but it's still hard triangle
detection is hard yeah yeah this is this
is basically how the hardness proof sold
proof works or like here I chose to make
these two the same
so this is this is the I'll show you
exactly the construction now
this is how I want to encode triangle
detection
so I pretend like I can put different
relations in different actions
so for three of the atoms I put the
edges for the fourth one I put equality
if I could do that I would be able to
find triangles
but now I'm only allowed to specify one
relation for everything
so what I do
is I tag all of the values with the
variable names according to the item
where I want them to go
and I take the union of all of these
things
and this is the relation that I put in
my input
and now what would be the answers over
this Construction
well the answers will all be that a
variable maps to some value that's
tagged by the variable itself
and why is it always the variable itself
because we find homomorphisms and in
particular the mapping from the variable
to the second component also has to be a
homomorphism
and the only homomorphism endomorphism
within the query is the identity because
the query doesn't have other
endomorphisms
so this works
one of the things you're taking your
whole triangle
hardensive thing the cross products
taking a product with this class yes I
think so
okay
uh it works because the query is a core
there are no endomorphins sorry
what did we consume some
like wz quality conditions oh sorry
okay
now what happens if we try to apply the
same proof on the query which we just
said we have an algorithm for why
wouldn't it work
so now I flip this Edge back
I do the same Construction
and now because of this endomorphism
that this is its image I also get the W
can maps to Y so I can get values where
W is mapped to something impacted by y
so I'll get answers that correspond to
two paths
so I have too many answers
I don't really detect triangles I also
detect two bats
okay
um so I said we don't know everything
about self joins we can generalize what
we saw before a bit so if a query sort
of looks like a mirror something like
this we know it's easy
if a query has a cyclic core like all of
the queries you see here we know it's
hard
things in between so queries are not a
mirror but having a cyclic core we don't
always know let me show you a few more
examples and things we know about them
before we go on a break
so secret is exactly the chord is what
sorry
or exactly it means that the core of the
query
the underlying graph if you ignore the
directions is a cycle
or
well in the binary case that's what it
means but it doesn't want to apply for
it
it just means yeah
if you take endomorphisms from the
homomorphisms from the query to itself
you take the core over this type of
stuff then what you get is Alpha cyclic
alpha alpha cyclic like yeah
the same notion of electricity as before
yes two inside three cups is quite
important like our uh it can be more
than two it would still the algorithm
would still work yeah well one is also
okay but uh it needs to be a cyclic so
then the query the cyclic we know it's
easy
okay
so
reordering variables inside an atom can
change the complexity of the query this
is something we didn't have without self
joins
very cool right
let's move on
to take a query uh the same query that
was easy before now we introduce a unary
atom
on the variable here
what happens to the complexity try to
guess
yes
right sorry
so before uh yeah this is where the
similarity to graph starts to be a bit
so before we had uh the we had an atom
that tells us r x y and an atom that
tells us r y z now I also introduce
another atom that says s of Y
so we have another relation it's a
urinary relation
so for example you can say I know that
some of the nodes are red I want the
query where this node is red
yeah thanks that's a
number
and then you can write um
okay
thanks
cool so I introduced a unary atom so I
have this pattern I want these graphs to
be spread whatever
what happens to the complexity
easy hard
um we can still reduce triangle
detection I won't go in the details but
what we get is that now not if we do
this reduction not all answers would
correspond to triangles we would still
have answers where this is the image but
then the answers will just correspond to
edges so it's not too many answers we
can still go over all of them and check
if we also have a child
uh but we won't have answers that
correspond to the image here this is not
an image right so we don't have too many
answers
[Applause]
okay yes
why couldn't the like
uh
other side that doesn't have the urinary
relation it can still like meet that
condition though right like yes it can
okay
which is
why answers to the image give you also
answers to the entire query
but you won't easily find all answers to
the entire query by going through those
so you can have a lot of things that
don't meet the condition
well you just look at all of your
answers and then some of those would
correspond to edges so the answer would
be everything is equal and this is one
Edge and some of the answers would
correspondence so just go over all of
the answers there aren't too many of
those until you see a triangle
and then if you don't see a triangle the
algorithm would finish quickly because
there aren't many answers if you do see
a triangle you would see it with linear
times
cool
so this is hard
introducing unary atoms can affect the
complexity
another example
do you think that it's easy or hard
it's hard you can do something similar
to before let's not spend too much time
on that because we want to continue I
just want to show you what happened
uh no I think the same thing as before I
add two spikes here
do you think that it's easy or hard
there were two things hard in a row
right you can't put a third hard thing
it is easy
the two spikes make it so that like so
this spikes make makes it so that this
is an image now
uh and now I have two images that sort
of cover the loop that's the hard part
of the query and then I can sort of find
the answers to the images and then
compare the images to check if they meet
and there is some algorithms
and we'll change the complexity that is
it doesn't it get absorbed in the
adjacent uh the binary relation it can
get absorbed in the adjacent relations
but then it's like you don't have a
self-joining the insulations are
different than the relations on the
other side where you don't have such a
thing that associated
you can use the urinary atom to filter
the adjacent relations right that's what
you said but then the adjacent relations
are smaller than the ones on the other
side of the query
but you have more than one reactions
right
in general we don't know anything I just
have specific examples right now
for example
can only make it harder
I think so
we don't have a complete classification
that that's all I know
I only know that we can make it harder
but if you introduce more than one you
could make it easy right make it look
like a secret well if you introduce
unary atoms everywhere it's as if you
didn't put them at all or like if you
put unit one unit atom here and one unit
atom on the other side it's a mirror and
then it's easy again so right so too so
adding them can make it easy
compared to one it can make it easier
but if you didn't have any one and now
you introduce one I'm not sure
yeah
um
just to like a labor a point so uh in in
the hard case where we have a unary atom
on just the left side yeah you add a
unitary item of uh at them on the right
side if it were the same condition
yeah it's the same unit oh if it's the
same unit atom then uh that's nearer it
becomes easy yeah
would be hard
um so like like how I guess I'm uh yeah
how would you generally want to classify
that then if like
it depends but I guess I would talk
about the type of endomorphisms in the
query and then you won't this won't be
able to map to the other one
I know foreign
relations are the same and this is one
other reason yeah so I like to think
about these as like
um in the graph case you have a paper
diagram
your notes you know okay partitions and
it seems like you're identifying some
partitions is that right
and so that's what's making the problem
you identify because the practitioners
certain things
okay so this is easy and
now we have three things introducing
spikes tourism unary atoms reordering
variables inside an atom these are
things that can affect the complexity
now but couldn't affect the complexity
so this is much more complicated and we
don't know what's going okay
uh let me just very quickly without
details
show you that it gets more complicated
than that here's
a query
is it easy or hard
how would you know right
it's easy
even though we don't have images that
cover the entire cycle
because we can somehow show that the
time we would need to compare the two
endpoints of the images we do have is
bounded by the amount of answers we
would get because we have so many spikes
okay but now if we take so this is easy
we take exactly the same query but now
we flip this Edge
now it is probably hard okay I can't
like I can't show you that it's hard
according to the same hypothesis I can
show you that it's hard according to a
different uh
in a moment
so it's really not just about the amount
of spikes it's because this Spike maps
to here and this is exactly what we need
to make it okay
ah so let me briefly say that uh we we
will go back to talking about this
hypothesis in the second part I'll make
sure we get to that even though I have
to cut on other things
uh but if we do this Construction
if we look at this image we have extra
answers where this Maps two edges and
this Spike also maps to edges here so
the number of extra answers would be
quadratic
in the number of edges that we have
which is not good it's not something we
can just go over before we find
triangles
um
but we can do that if we assume that
we're finding triangles in a tripartite
graph and here we have a small set of
edges
and then quadratic in the small set of
edges would work
uh so we had to define vertex and
balance triangle detection for something
else on unions of conjunctive queries
which I will get to later and I'll tell
you why we had to Define this but if we
take this hypothesis
uh then it allows us to do the reduction
and the hypothesis says we have a
tripartite graph with one large set of
uh
then it's not possible to determine if
it has triangles in time
um that's basically linear in the worst
case input size
but if the matrix multiplication
exponent is 2. you could do that
yes in particular this is
okay uh that's a nice image of how votd
vertical bios triangle detection is
stronger or implies the two things we
had to use before there shouldn't be an
edge here I think it shouldn't be an
Excellence lipstick but it's stronger
than these two things
um so we could replace everything else
by just using that uh but let's not
spend too much time on that this is hard
and what about this query here we don't
have unary atoms anymore is it easy or
hard
okay
so this is an open problem so even
let me rephrase the General open problem
okay we have we don't need unitary
relations to make it open okay I have an
undirected graph
is it possible to enumerate all
homomorphisms from this undirected graph
to an input undirected graph with linear
pre-processing and constant delay what's
the property of the patterns that I can
do that and the property of the patterns
where I cannot do that or for this
specific one can I do this for now
human direct immigration directed yes
thank you
and yeah what is the smallest golden
problem
I wouldn't just bug you with that if it
wasn't even though like it's a ghost
oh
okay uh you mean that literally so like
all six node graphs you know the answer
no I don't know
the smallest one that I thought
I thought maybe we can like one of the
discussion questions is from the
smallest things
okay
um let's take
let's take five minutes uh if you want
to go to the bathrooms stretch or
whatever and we'll go back here and
continue and we probably won't get to
the last part but I think the questions
and discussions
thank you
oh I only have like I only have 15
minutes left right
yeah I mean
quickly